[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so I've been talking about Matrix
Systems of differential equations things
like x dot equals a matrix a times x
where X is is a state vector and a is a
matrix and I've been talking a lot about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this a
matrix we've been looking at for
different a matrices what are the
eigenvalues what are the eigenvectors
and what are the implications for using
that to solve the system so I say in
words a lot that this Matrix a has
stable eigenvalues or unstable
eigenvalues and so I want to kind of
clarify and slow down a little bit in
this lecture and just very clearly tell
you what I mean by you know what
does it mean what does it mean really
to have you know stable
or unstable eigenvalues
okay because this is a big deal and I'm
gonna I like I use this this phrasing
all the time and I realized maybe you
don't know what I mean when I say the a
matrix has stable eigenvalue so I want
to just dive in and make it very very
clear
um
we know for example when we talk about
stability if I talk about you know a
really simple differential equation like
X double dot plus
3 x dot plus two x equals zero we know
that the solutions of this differential
equation are things like uh you know X
of T equals there's two fundamental
Solutions you can find from the
characteristic polynomial
and those two characteristic Solutions
are e to the minus t and e to the minus
2T and so any linear combination of
these two solutions is also a solution
to this differential equation
and we would say
is stable
fundamental Solutions are stable
exponential it's stable because
all fundamental Solutions
kind of in this case there's only two
fundamental Solutions but all the
fundamental Solutions e to the minus t
and e to the minus 2T
are in fact stable
and literally what that means is if I
plot these functions
as functions of time they are decaying
exponentials the Decay to zero as time
goes to Infinity so this is stable
because the solution goes to zero it
remains bounded and in fact converges to
zero asymptotically as T goes to
Infinity as time goes to Infinity so
that's what it means for this to be
stable is that all of these powers of e
to the minus t and e to the minus two t
are stable they have negative they're
negative real numbers so e to a negative
real number T is going to get you know
arbitrarily small as T goes to Infinity
so how does that translate over to these
Matrix Systems of differential equations
well we know in this Matrix system we're
going to be talking about things like
eigenvalues and eigenvectors so we have
a times T equals
T times D where these are my eigenvalues
and these are my eigen vectors
and specifically what this eigen
decomposition allows me to do is it
allows me to write the solution of this
differential equation in terms of these
T's and D's in the following way
so we can write that X of T the solution
of my system at time T is equal to
um
T times e to this diagonal matrix D time
times T inverse times x naught
and all of the action here the only term
that depends on time here is this e to
the diagonal matrix DT everything else
is just a linear combination of the
terms in this diagonal matrix so I'm
going to zoom in on this for a minute
we're going to zoom in on this e to the
diagonal T So e to the diagonal matrix t
is a matrix a diagonal matrix
of e to all of my my eigenvalues uh in
of my Matrix so this is like e to my
first eigenvalue t e to my second
eigenvalue T dot dot dot dot e to my nth
eigenvalue T assuming that I have an N
by n square a matrix and everything else
is zero
and so here's what I mean for an
eigenvalue to be stable for this Matrix
system of equations x dot equals ax to
be stable what it means is that every
single term in this diagonal matrix e to
the DT every single term here has to be
stable all of these have to be bounded
remain bounded and Decay to zero as T
goes to Infinity for this to be a stable
system because I'm going to be taking
these combinations this T Matrix and
this T inverse these are invertible
matrices so I'm taking a combination of
all of these e to the Lambda T's and
folding them up to build X of T and so
if even a single one of these is
unstable then my system is unstable so
let me write that out so uh x dot equals
a x is stable
if
all eigenvalues
Lambda
are stable
and I'm going to say I'll tell you what
that means in a minute it means they all
have negative real part okay and it's
unstable
if even one
or at least one if even a single
eigenvalue
is unstable
okay and now does that make sense
because if even one of these terms blows
up to infinity and all of the other ones
are stable let's say you know all of
them are stable except for this one and
this one blows up to Infinity because
it's unstable when I take this linear
combination of all of these terms and I
fold this up X of T is still going to
blow up to Infinity because this term is
going to dominate everything else and
it's going to blow up to Infinity so
even One Bad Apple One unstable
eigenvalue is going to blow up my whole
solution and my system's unstable so all
of the eigenvalues have to all of these
behaviors have to be stable for my
global system to be stable okay so now
I'm going to show you what it means for
an eigenvalue to be stable here this was
pretty simple because these are real
valued lambdas if we did our
characteristic equation Lambda squared
plus 3 Lambda plus two equals zero we
find that Lambda equals minus one and
minus two so these are both real valued
lambdas and they're stable because
they're negative okay e to the negative
power T is stable e to the positive
power T is unstable
Matrix system these I
design complex conjugate pairs so it's a
little more subtle than that
okay so my Lambda my lambdas could come
in complex conjugate pairs a plus I B
and of course if I had an A plus IB for
a real valued Matrix I would also have
to have another eigenvalue a minus IB
but let's just look at this one for now
okay and so if I take e to the Lambda t
that equals e to the A Plus let's say a
t
plus i b t because I can multiply both
of these by T and because of the
property of exponentials e to the a t
plus IBT equals e to the a t
times e to the i b t this is this is
really really useful and now finally I'm
going to use Euler's formula to expand
this out and we're going to see that
this equals e to the the real part A T
times something like cosine b t plus I
sine b t
and what I want to point out here is
that this number has kind of unit length
that's a complex number you know it's
got a real and an imaginary part but
this has a unit length the real part
squared plus the imaginary part squared
is cosine squared plus sine squared
equals one this has unit length in the
complex plane this is like unit
length or size or Norm sometimes we call
it Norm unit Norm in the complex plane
and the only thing that can make this
solution blow up or Decay is this e to
the a t so this
scales the solution this scales
the solution this kind of oscillating
solution if I have a plus IB then I get
some oscillation at frequency B and this
real part here this real part of Lambda
so the real part of Lambda is what
determines stability
determines
stability
because if this
oscillating part is multiplied by e to
the positive a t that's going to blow up
to Infinity that's going to be unstable
so if a is positive my system is
unstable if a is negative this is e to
the minus number T it will be stable and
Decay to zero so in this case here that
I've drawn if I have like a less than
zero this Alpha sorry it's not Alpha
it's a if a is less than zero
maybe really careful here not to confuse
you with bad symbol writing
if the real part of my eigenvalue is
less than zero and I have some you know
maybe I have some plus IB so I have some
oscillation I'm going to get
an oscillation multiplied by this
decaying exponential envelope so I'm
going to have my solution look stable as
time goes to Infinity okay that's what I
mean by a less than zero gives me a
stable system and similarly maybe I'll
move this over a little bit so this is
the
um
a less than zero if I look at the a
greater than zero case
if I have the uh a greater than zero
case so the real part of my eigenvalue
is greater than zero now I'm multiplying
this by a growing exponential envelope
so now my my envelope is growing
exponentially in time
and so now my oscillation is going to be
growing in amplitude and this would be
an unstable system
a greater than zero if my real part of
my eigenvalue is greater than zero then
it's unstable
and if a equals zero so I only have this
oscillating part we call that neutrally
stable it's it is bounded and it's not
blowing up to Infinity but it's also not
decaying to zero it's just kind of Sines
and cosines and it's going to oscillate
at the same amplitude forever if a
equals zero so this is super duper
important so and what I mean by stable
here is stable
a stable Lambda
has negative
real part
the imaginary part has nothing to do
with the stability of that eigenvalue
just causes us it to oscillate at a
frequency B but the real part of all of
these lambdas have to be negative for
this system to be stable and eigenvalue
Lambda is stable if it has a negative
real part and it's unstable
an unstable
Lambda has positive
real part
in the complex plane and so any
land if I have a single eigenvalue of my
system if even one of my eigenvalues of
a has a positive real part the whole
system is unstable that's how it works
okay so I hope this kind of clears it up
for you I'm going to use this
terminology like you're going to hear it
so many times don't make a drinking game
out of me talking about stable
eigenvalues uh and I wanted you to know
what I meant by that and so it's
literally if I if I plot my eigenvalues
in the complex plane so here's the
complex plane and let's say I've got a
bunch of eigenvalues and I've got you
know negative 1 negative two nice and
stable nice and stable I've got you know
negative 1.7 plus I negative 1.7 minus I
I've got a bunch of stable eigenvalues
any eigenvalue in this left half plane
is stable
this is called the stable left half
plane because if eigenvalues live in
this plane where the real part these
axes sorry I should draw the axes this
is the real part of Lambda and this is
the imaginary part of Lambda which I've
called you know B here and I've called a
here if my real part is negative all of
these eigenvalues are stable and if my
real part is positive if I have an
eigenvalue out here or here these are
unstable eigenvalues okay so I have the
stable left half plane and the unstable
right half plane and this is going to
come up a bunch in control theory we
call these poles of a system
um in control theory
um you know but they're really just the
lambdas the roots of my my sorry the
eigenvalues of my a matrix or the roots
of my characteristic polynomial and this
is how we Define stability and similarly
any points here are neutrally stable if
they're perfectly on the imaginary axis
they're mutually stable
okay I really
because I I need you to have this kind
of deep intuition and gut feeling of
what it means for an eigenvalue to be
stable and eigenvalue this a matrix is
stable if it's real part is negative and
it's unstable if it's real part is
positive and for a system I mean all of
the eigenvalues to be stable for this
system to be stable all right thank you
[Music]
foreign